when I heard that they are putting this
legendary story of the marvel humans on
a screen I was very excited I'm when I
heard that they were doing it in IMAX
that made me even more excited because I
love IMAX and I loved how big and how
involved he can be we need to go to
earth now we've been hiding here too
long let's go to our rightful home with
Inhumans you're talking about a group of
people who are trying to maintain some
semblance of a family but are ripped
apart because of the responsibilities of
them being royal I think everyone around
the world relates to family drama and
that's pretty much what I've been humans
all about right or wrong he's dangerous
the first episodes of Marvel's of humans
will be premiered in IMAX theaters if
you are a fan of the Marvel Universe you
want to see everything you want to see
these details it really immerses you and
you really get to see all these amazing
colors and effects just for me looking
through it on the monitor is some of the
most beautiful footage I've ever seen in
my life it's the stuff another level
that you get let in to the world that
you're watching it's gonna give
everything a much larger scale which is
really exciting
I love that for a television show that
is designed to be in the intimacy of
your home that we're starting in this
epic way to be a part of a show that is
harnessing the power of IMAX ABC and
Marvel it really is going to be like in
a medium experience
[Music]